composé une musique sans instrument
c'est tout le concept de ce nouvel opus
sorti en février pour l'élaboration de
ses cinq titres laura mauget n'utilise
qu'un micro et un ordinateur depuis son
salon c'est à partir de cette base
musicale à la voix et aux percussions
corporelles qu'est né le titre brief
[Musique]
la tuque un livre que tu es
ça permet d'avoir du temps puisque c'est
vrai que quand on joue en tout cas avant
le cockpit moi j'avais quand même la
chance d'avoir énormément de concerts et
j'adore la scène donc c'était formidable
mais c'est vrai que par contre toutes
les idées de chansons que j'avais dans
la tête elles sont enregistrées sur un
bout de dictaphone ou parfois couché sur
le coin d'une feuille quelques lignes en
vrac mais j'avais jamais le temps de les
finaliser d enregistrer et du coup bah
c'est vrai que là pour le coup on a
suffisamment de temps pour se poser se
dire ça y est c'est bon je peux
consacrer du temps à sa
très attachée à son indépendance
musicale laura se balade entre le blues
la soul le jazz l'écriture en français
ou en anglais la scène en groupe ou en
solo pour ses prochaines apparitions en
public la chanteuse prépare et piano à
la demande avec dans ce répertoire une
centaine de reprises
au prénom il ya une liste
deux chansons
en tout genre des années 30 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en anglais en français qui
comprend également mes compositions et
donc c'est le public qui sera présent le
soir du concert qui va pouvoir choisir
demandé les titres qui souhaite que
j'interprète ce soir là pour l'artiste
berruyères les concerts reprennent enfin
a pris deux ans en dents de scie elle se
produira notamment au bar de 62 à
l'hôtel bourgon pour plusieurs dates le
sens de ce côté ci ouais ou alors ici
avant la reprise laura peaufine les
derniers détails
j'ai donné beaucoup de ma personne
pendant les 2 confinement j'ai joué tous
les jours à la maison pour pour les gens
mais
malgré tout moi je suis vraiment une
femme de scène c'est ce que j'aime
nourrir du public de l'interaction voit
la femme au service arabe de
mairie comme semaine
[Musique]
b
laura mauger renoue avec la scène locale
pour plusieurs rendez vous mais ne
délaisse pas pour autant la composition
elle travaille notamment sur un loupé en
français intitulé livre de vie
[Musique]
les
bébés
aux sports de warda
[Musique]
et